Aportamos técnicas y medios modernos,
como el diseño centrado en el usuario o la nube,
y ayudamos a mejorar los procesos de adquisición.
Resulta que la administración compra programas informáticos
del mismo modo que compra sillas, bizcochos o tanques:
aplicando más de 1000 páginas de normas.
Sí, ciertas cosas de la administración son algo caóticas ahora mismo.
Pero si creen que Silicon Valley es el rescatador en esta historia,
(Risas)
está Uds. muy equivocados.
Algunas de las mentes más brillantes del mundo de la tecnología
están creando empresas de reparto de comidas,
de patinetes,
o ideando el mejor modo de distribuir hierba.
¿De verdad no hay cosas más importantes ahora mismo?
A Silicon Valley le gusta hablar de mejorar el mundo.
Pero percibes tu impacto de forma mucho más visceral
en la administración.
Esto es de alguien que perdió a su padre.
Me buscó en Twitter
para decirme que un sistema que habíamos mejorado
le ayudó en un momento muy duro.
Es en esos momentos duros cuando la administración debe funcionar.
Y por eso necesitamos innovar en este ámbito.
Tengo que confesaros algo.
Cuando vine a la capital,
a veces usaba palabras como "burócrata".
Últimamente,
es más probable que use otras como "servidor público".
Como Francine, que te puede hacer llorar.
Al menos, a mí me hizo llorar,
por el ánimo que infunde.
Estoy también profundamente orgulloso de mis colegas.
No paran hasta resolver situaciones ilógicas,
perdiendo horas de sueño hasta obtener el resultado buscado.
Como la administración no puede pagar grandes bonificaciones,
nos inventamos nuestros propios premios.
Nuestra mascota es el cangrejo Molly,
así que el premio es, de hecho, un bolso con forma de cangrejo,
atornillado a una placa de metal.
Hoy en día ya no creo tanto en soluciones mágicas
que vayan a arreglarlo todo.
Creo más en las personas
que están ahí para ayudar.
Si buscan algo que tenga un sentido profundo,
y, les seré sincero, algo que puede ser a veces terriblemente frustrante,
deben saber esto.
Se produce algo difícil y complicado,
y también vital y mágico,
cuando los funcionarios públicos se asocian con los tecnólogos
en todos los niveles: municipal, estatal y nacional.
No tiene por qué ser para siempre.
Pero pueden contribuir mucho a cambiar las cosas
desde ya.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)